welcome back to new rockstars doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness was
confirmed to undergo a key rewrite when
it comes to its connection with
wandavision
elizabeth olsen is now teasing fans
we'll be surprised that
she can't wait to see her reaction to
this quote one division
part leading us to ask once again
well this is inside marvel i'm eric boss
here with mt how you feeling mt
i'm feeling good i'm feeling curious
more than anything because like
what is what is she talking about i
don't know every time these actors just
say like oh there's a big candy i'm
coming to surprise
it doesn't matter how many times we get
burned we will always chase them down
that hole
exactly it's just it's just so like we
just want more wanda vision slash wanda
maxim off
anything so like anything that can they
can tease us we're just gonna get
excited about it because
why not it's a marvel cinematic universe
let's go right now and we need stuff to
talk about loki's not back yet um so
oh by the way we are spending these
weeks waiting for loki doing a kind of
phase four preview and uh one of the
biggest marvel titles ahead is obviously
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness it's less than a year away
which means yeah we're gonna start to
hear more and more about this movie so
today
mt and i are gonna dive into this whole
one division scene what it will be
in the multiverse of madness and really
everything else we know about this uh dr
strange sequel
oh a quick reminder that you gotta check
out newrockstarsmerch.com for all of our
great merch options we got shirts like
like this one that you can get but like
cooler designs than that
on hoodies and jackets water bottles
really whatever you need uh you can find
it at newrockstarsmerch.com but mt
let's dive into this what's our first
wtf well our first
wonder the f of the day is wtf will be
this one division scene in multiverse of
madness uh yes
all right so remember in interviews last
month kevin feige and one division show
runner jack shafer revealed that the
original plan
was to include a doctor strange cameo in
the one division finale
and that strange was going to be the
actual source of those injuries
fun i would have loved great oh but it's
true in our head canon hopefully i'm cu
cannon
soon soon uh so this means that that
stark toaster the structure watch hydra
soaked lagos paper towels uh yo magic
yogurt and nexus antidepressants these
were all various messages
from dr strange just warped by the west
view hex to fit
into wanda sitcom aesthetic and feige
said that removing doctor strange
from the finale led to rewrites for
multiverse of madness to explain what
wanda's link would be from one division
and now elizabeth olsen just told
glamour spain that multiverse of madness
is sure to surprise fans saying quote i
can't wait to see your reaction
especially when it comes to the
wanda vision part
okay okay okay elizabeth what you got
for us
what'd you say for us well if you try to
like read her mind here olsen did say in
that interview last month that
wanda had retreated to that remote
mountain cabin specifically to use her
words here
because she knew she would be held
accountable
she's on the run and it knows that
there's gonna be another shoe that drops
there's gonna be some kind of justice
some kind of turn for her uh where that
means she's gonna be on a different side
of this coming battle and
breaking apart that scene again in that
cabin wanda was using astral projection
to scour the dark hold while her
physical form was brewing tea
which makes it an advanced form of this
spell because every other time we've
seen a sorcerer do this in the mcu
the physical body has had to be
incapacitated not just to sleep we saw
the ancient one was
basically on her deathbed the other um
kaiselius drammu zealot that he fought
in the sanctum
uh was his body was incapacitated you
saw his body fall back
so wanda doesn't have to fall back here
yeah and like with when the ancient one
pushed you know doctor strange's
right spirit out of his body in that
amazing trip sequence in the first movie
he was
unconscious when bruce banner got
knocked out of uh the body of uh smart
exactly the same thing happened
um and while all this happens we hear
the doctor strange theme music playing
and
the camera swoops into the cabin uh
and the camera movement doesn't edit or
cut or anything
across the lake as it goes to the back
room of the cabin which yeah a lot of us
have compared to sam raimi's camera work
in evil dead
sam raymond's directing dr strange
multiverse madness so um
as the scarlet witch is flipping through
the dark hold we hear the voices of her
children crying out for help
implying that she might have been
searching the multiverse for a reality
where her children exist
and that her children might be in some
kind of peril or
someone is using the sound of them being
apparel as
bait for wanda that'd be a good
definitely missing her kids right i'm
right about then uh-huh uh-huh
yummy bait that's a live cricket on the
end of that hook right there
so i think we can assume empty that this
rewritten wanda multiverse of madness
scene will tie into all that and
i see two options i want to hear what
your thoughts are
um but the first idea after this is that
maybe in desperation to bring her kids
back wanda casts another hex
which as a nexus being breaks reality
causing a multiverse of madness and
making wanda a house of m-style
antagonists that we kind of expected her
to become in one division yeah and that
this new scene in multiverse madness
could be a flashback with strange
instinctive sanctorum
casting spells to try to warn wanda and
westview to drop the hex
and come talk with him talk to the
doctor
but that his messages fail uh and they
just show up as commercials that no one
understands and then
after he consults with agatha harkness
he tracks down wanda to that cabin
maybe his astral projection is the
camera point of view
and that strange and wanda have an
astral projection fight and that's how
the movie opens
okay so like we would technically have
been doctor strange in that sequence in
wanda vision where we see her
okay yeah i like that and like it sort
of like retroactively
um enacts those original kevin feige
plans of having
doctor strange um be responsible for
those commercials so
i love that i hope that they do that
because like oh man
like those are those are like the best
parts of one division and
they haven't really explained them yet
so that would be a great explanation
yeah like maybe the moment she like
wakes up in cognition when she hears the
voices
like she's looking up at strange in that
moment he snaps the dark hole
shut tries to take a proper like do not
around with this
god that would be dope that would be
such a cool reveal that'd be fun maybe
not the opening scene be fun to see that
at some point in the movie
um but i want to quickly share the
second option for what this
one division was madison could be maybe
the scene makes wanda less of a villain
and more of an
unaware antagonist in the movie uh like
in this scenario maybe the voices she
hears from the darkhold are really not
her children but some malevolent entity
tricking wanda into thinking it's her
children in order to stage some faustian
bargain with wanda
for her children in exchange for her
nexus powers
really creating this greater threat that
wanda and strange have to team up to
fight
and this demon could be someone like
nightmare actually schumachorath has
been rumored
oh yes or yes it could be our daddy
mephisto
[Laughter]
daddy m oh my god daddy
yeah you guys all know i was still on
the mepisto train after that post credit
scene and really even more so after the
show runner revealed that agatha's
rabbit
was supposed to be a demon in disguise
no obviously not everything in the show
was a mephisto clue
so you can stop tweeting me those stale
memes
seriously find a new joke super whack at
this point
please just stop find a new thing that
makes fun of me for how about that and
watch
any video on new rockstars you can find
something that you can make fun of me
for
tweet me that just something new give me
something new uh i don't care if you
make fun of me
um but uh actually catherine hahn
recently said that agatha was not under
the influence of mephisto she debunked
that theory
but um that doesn't mean wanda is not
still vulnerable to people
like him or him himself um because we
never got answers on
billy and tommy because the way they
entered this universe was not the same
way
wanda uh invoked vision in in
west view right true kind of came about
through some other means and there was
that weird line the finale where wanda
said thanks for
choosing me to be your mom which like
that's not how it works
the historic doesn't choose you like if
they were born from your womb they
didn't
like their souls didn't come this isn't
uh what's it called um
soul
i want that one yeah i feel like the
rules of soul are now canon in the mcu
now i think that's what kevin feige
i think the rules of soul are canon in
our lives
i recently saw seoul and like i love
that movie it's so good it's such
amazing
so beautiful so yeah we don't really
know what these kids voices
from the dark hold mean that's obviously
a big mystery that they want us to pour
over as we head into multiverse of
madness so
i think in this case we might see an
opening scene to this movie with wanda
in that cabin casting a hex with a dark
hold
finding what she thinks are her children
but then getting drained of her powers
by some demon
whether that be or nightmare or mobisto
while strange races to free wanda from
this stranglehold but without killing
her because he's a doctor he doesn't
want to do any harm
yeah what do you what do you think of
that version and which do you think is
uh more likely and do you have any
thoughts on this what this week i really
do like
that uh that entity thing as well
because like with the dark hole the dark
hold is this super ancient
book that has ties to i believe the the
many angled ones
uh which is uh which is what um
schumacherath is and because we're
getting all these
really you know prevalent rumors that
schumacher may be the villain of
doctor strange too i i'm sort of like
you know what
option two may actually be happening
because you know
in the comics um these many angled
beings
have used these books to try to weasel
their way
into our reality so maybe a schumer
gorath or or some other
entity is trying to trying to do that
and uh use wanda so
with the presence of the dark hold is a
very big indicator of an option two
um happening in my opinion but i really
just want to see
option one because those commercials
need to be explained and i just i want
doctor strange to to
acknowledge the commercials because yeah
this will be great do you think it's
possible that the opening scene could
just be something simpler where it's
agatha hartness catherine hahn in west
view brewing tea
or gardening with some vunigar ever
bloom and then strange shows up in a
portal and it's just them talking
because i think that would be totally
fine by me yeah i
i would totally just be cool just to see
catherine hahn again and just in general
um and just to see doctor strange too
sort of like progress her story it's
like all right now
i'm gonna remove you from this curse
that want to put you under and like
maybe you're going to come help me out
or like maybe or like maybe um
she gets a visit for moto i don't know
like i just oh yeah i just want to see
katherine han hardcore yeah and you got
to think like if you're coming out of
one division
and like you're in the midst of it
you're seeing how popular this show has
become specifically how
crazy fans are going over the character
of agatha uh someone if you're kevin
feig you're like i gotta find a way to
get agatha and multiverse of madness
because she's such a breakout star
of that show i mean everyone on the show
is breakout but specifically agatha
in particular and that's one like yeah
there's probably pl whatever direction
they're going to multiverse madness
you can definitely have the witch of
west view agatha harkness show up
somewhere in that store oh yeah you
could fit her in
easily because she's such a crucial
component as to why it's even happening
in the first one
yeah of course sure for sure so uh let
us know in the comments below what you
think this
new uh wanda vision-esque scene a
multiverse of madness will be that
elizabeth olson's
hype in us up for or whether you think
it's all and then they make no
reference at all to want to mention
other than
the fact that she's in it it's all just
a lie
well we have a whole bunch of other
questions about multi-purpose madness
that we're going to get to in a second
first we want to thank some friends who
helped us make this episode thank you to
keeps for sponsoring this episode more
than 50 million men in the us suffer
from male pattern baldness and there are
only two
fda approved medications to prevent hair
loss good news
keeps offers both of them keeps has a
simple stress-free way
to keep your hair i personally hate
going to doctor's appointments in
general it's never a convenient time
you have to park you got to sit in a
waiting room it's about as much fun as
losing your hair
is well keeps offers convenient virtual
doctors consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your home
to go to the doctor or to the pharmacy
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and
keeps offers generic versions to keep
costs
low their proven results arrive on your
doorstep in discrete packaging keep says
more five-star reviews than any of its
competitors
with hair loss prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so
you gotta act fast so if like mt if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash marvel
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash marvel to get your first
month free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
marvel we also wanna thank bespoke post
for sponsoring this episode bespoke
post's new lineup of essential box of
awesome collections for guys
are guaranteed to upgrade your life no
matter what you are into
some of my favorite boxes from the past
have had great shirts i wear all the
time cool kitchen equipment and some fun
travel gear whether out tame in the
wilderness or
taking your home bar game to pro level
heights bespoke post only sends guys the
best stuff every month box of
awesomeness collections for every part
of your life
their new explore box comes with cool
gear that you can use to go off and the
wilderness and the julep box comes with
everything you need to make a fancy mint
julep cocktail to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel
anytime each box only costs 45 bucks but
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code marvel
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code marvel
for 20 off your first box and thank you
to bluetooth for sponsoring this video
our friends at luchu have a unique
online service that delivers these same
active ingredients as viagra in cialis
but in chewable format at a fraction of
the cost bluechu is an online
prescription service so no doctor's
office or pharmacy trips it ships right
to your door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength and blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name which is
great news for folks who don't like
swallowing pills
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth for free when you
use our promo code inside marvel at
checkout
just pay five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month for free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the episode uh mt i want to ask you our
next
wand of the uh what do you think will be
the role of zochi gomez as america
chavez in the show
well first of all i have been dying for
america chavez for a long time so i am
so excited to see america chavez in
doctor strange too it's gonna be great i
think that
the role of america chavez in in doctor
strange too is going to be tied to
obviously
you know um wanda's kids billy and tommy
but mostly billy because in the comics
um
i believe billy is uh this being called
the demiurge that created
uh america chavez in the first place so
i think that whether or not
america chavez uh utopian uh dimension
roots are going to be at play here in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
um i think that you know billy could end
up becoming this this force that did
create
um america chavez in another dimension
i don't know i like that idea a lot of
her being linked with billy
billy there um yeah i wonder if like um
it you know doctor strange has
experience navigating the multiverse to
an extent
but like i have to wonder if like the
way he travels the multiverse is just
kind of the
long route and then you know you know
america chavez has that whole way of
like kicking stars
portals through realities maybe she's
like why don't you just go this way
and she's gonna help him she's gonna be
like uh the guide
you know to show them all the shortcuts
to get from reality to reality because
for her that's like second nature
right they'll probably like meet each
other like like in the space between
dimensions like
wait a minute how are you doing that so
you have portals like you can just
make little star portals so fast like
can i just tag along with you
because like yeah you just like
hitchhikes with america's office
it's like hey i'm just looking for a
ride you know right yeah or maybe
there's some kind of like um
uh like the multiverse kind of like all
the highways and bridges are shut down
you know when wanda takes it over or she
breaks reality or whoever
is the antagonist here they kind of make
it hard to navigate the multiverse
so strange's old ways don't work as well
his magic because we know the magic of
the scarlet witch
surpasses that of the sorcerer's supreme
right yeah so strange might need to team
up with someone else with experience of
navigating the multiverse so that he can
hop from
university university university
universe and find his way to the core
wherever wanda or the demonic entity
controlling her is
that's very i like that cause like wando
could very well be the one who shuts
strange out of like those multiversal
pathways and like so you'll have to like
you know rely on america chavez to go
around i do like that that's a good idea
yeah i'm just so excited to see
how they depict this visually because in
the first dr strange film they were
using a lot of jack kirby inspired oh
yes
kirby yes super lsd neon glowing stuff
with you know hands folding in the hands
becoming an eye
becoming so cool like dark dimension is
peak kirby it's just amazing it's great
so
are they going to build on that um are
they going to
come up with some kind of new visual
language to show what it looks like to
you know travel from university universe
well i mean
raymie is a big doctor strange fan and
so he's although he's been wanting to do
something like this for
a long time so like yeah we're gonna see
some real like
classic trippy visuals again um with
with dr strange who probably even more
than scott derrickson did
honestly um but i think isn't derrickson
still involved in this project
to some he might be credited as a
producer but he's no longer the director
and the script has been pretty
rewritten i think from where it was when
he was developing it so
i mean the guy they're getting as a
production designer for multiverse of
madison is charles wood who's been a
production designer on
pretty like everything in marvel so uh
we wore
like end game infinity uh the first
doctor strange guardians of the galaxy
so like he's a long time marvel guy he
is like
but he knows what he's doing when it
comes to building these worlds and
oh yeah for sure making them both
functional and beautiful to look at all
right so what is our next
wanda the our next one of the day
is so the first movie ended with mordo
warning
viewers and doctor strange too many
sorcerers and the bill comes due
what the will mordo do in multiverse of
madness
yeah um because he's coming back he's
confirmed to be part of this plot
um i i think like his mission is going
to be to kill wanda i think that's going
to be the difference between him and
strange
is like they both are kind of on the
same side of the fight but strange as
the ultimate doctor
doesn't want to kill her he wants to
find a way to heal whatever she's going
through
whereas mordo's just like no we got too
many sorcerers on this world
we're gonna be better off if we just
kill them off oh yeah
mordo is definitely going to you know
look at those events of one division and
be like this woman is too
dangerous to be left alive because she's
she's very
it's unstable and like that's the same
struggle that the the avengers in the
comics go through which is like
do we kill wanda like should we because
like she's a real problem
so you know more like you said like
mordo and strange
technically have the same goal of you
know neutralizing the threat that is
wanda but
mordo is just like we have to just do
what needs to be done whereas dr strange
like you said
is a doctor so she's like you know i'm
gonna heal wanda rather than
you know off her because that's that's
not nice if they do a version of that
scene from house of m where all the
avengers in x-men are in the room
they're like so what do we do
right now i was actually reading that
today so good oh
oh it's great uh you know mordo's gonna
be already
with the pillow over her face like what
have we not decided this yet
i said too many sorcerers it's already
done guys it's it's
she's dead she's god she's gone cool
dairy queen but like hairy queen yeah
you mean baskin robbins oh yeah uh yeah
that's the ice cream store of the mcu
yeah
tuna melts tuna melts on me yeah but no
speaking of mordo um like i was saying
earlier i think it would be great to see
a scene between mordo and
agatha harkness because agatha was a
person that abused magic
and wanda let her live but mordo could
just
want to kill agatha and maybe um doctor
strange will stop bordeaux from killing
agatha
and that's that's that little scene in
tai tawan division
oh that'd be cool that'd be really
really neat um but yeah uh
wanda and uh agatha might very well be
on this man list
yeah oh absolutely they would be yeah
you know he was like just
stating outside west view just pacing
like right
here back and forth waiting for waiting
for the portal i mean
waiting for the heck to open it's just
like come on come on it's just like
testing it with a pitchfork
but before we move on we also want to
thank our friends at helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode so whether your
day job is being a master of mystic arts
a billionaire playboy
philanthropist or an accountant at the
end of the day you want to sleep in a
bed designed to fit your specific needs
well helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses a mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz and i got
matched with the
dusk lux helix mattress because i wanted
a medium firm mattress with lumbar
support that sleeps cool
i sleep great on my helix mattress the
mattress shifts right to your door for
free
and you never need to go to a mattress
store ever again they were awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine
just go to helix sleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our audience at helix sleep dot com
slash inside marvel that's helix sleep
dot com slash inside marvel
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
all right mt
i'm curious um so doctor strange will
appear in spiderman no way home
before the multiverse of madness even
though the original plan was
that third spider-man movie was going to
come out after multiverse of madness
before
kovid shuffled everything around so how
do you think the story of no way home
might connect to multiverse of madness
or will it connect
with doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness
and obviously spider-man no way home i
think the the tie that connects them
there is
obviously the spider-verse and with i
think that at the very least
i if doctor strange is probably going to
show up at the end maybe with a madame
webb maybe he's talking to a madam web
just sort of introducing that concept to
the multiverse because
he's essentially the the sort of
ambassador of the multiverse at this
point because he's the
marvel hero that we're following along
at um
while we get introduced to the
multiverse um so
i think that you know there will be some
type of
madame webb like here peter like this is
this is the multiverse and like here's
this weird spider
part of the multiverse and like i don't
know like it's
it'll probably be more of like a
explanation
type of deal because i don't think
there's really anyone else
in this in the spider man
universe that could explain the concept
of the multiverse
as well as doctor strange is other than
a madame webb
yeah but what do you think how do you
think it's gonna connect yeah i agree
auntie i i think
the they're gonna start to explore part
of the multiverse
in uh no way home but i think part of
that conversation is also starting in
loki you know i think what we're about
to find out is that
the multiverse has always been there in
the uc which we've known we've known
from the first doctor strange movie
you know the multiverse is a thing that
exists in the mcu and
there's not gonna be one big multiverse
crisis necessarily there's just gonna be
like
ripple effects there's gonna be some
kind of um consequence of the multiverse
uh here there's gonna be another
consequence over here and like
you know the multiverse yes connects all
of it but it's just like all of
existence connects all of it as well if
that makes sense it's not like oh
because dock and electro and maybe green
goblin spilled over into spider-man's
world over here that's because of what
wanda did
it might just be like wanda's multiverse
crisis
exists separate from the spider-verse
crisis exists separate from
the loki tva crisis but they all use the
mechanics of the multiverse and that
each one of these
sheds light on the multiverse in a
different way to give us a fuller
perspective of it as we move forward
yeah i think that's that's super likely
because like you got to think of like
the multiverse sort of like
you know space in like galaxies like
universes
our universe is just one galaxy in a sea
of galaxies so like there could be so
many different things happening
in uh different little pockets so like
yeah i do like that because it makes a
lot of
rational sense and that's a great
metaphor for that mt because like
the events of thor ragnarok the events
of captain marvel the events of
guardians of the galaxy they all just
exist
in space you know yeah it doesn't mean
because it's not on earth that they all
have to be connected
in fact you could say because it exists
doesn't exist on earth they're even
further apart from each other because
earth is just one tiny pale blue dot in
this universe
and that's kind of what makes it so
exciting also i just want to point out
um space here is space i'm in space
empty you're in space faces everywhere
earth is part of space
so it's just it's the same thing like
we're in a multiverse right now
multiverse is everywhere
you know so like i have to go into the
multiverse you're in it you're in my
friend we're already here man
yeah man everyone except for probably
maybe moebius in the tva
they're probably outside of diving space
or whatever but like everyone else yes
uwater the watcher you get a hall pass
everyone else yeah
you're in it sorry it sucks here but
just suck it up yeah all right mt what's
our uh
next uh what the wanda wanda the who
who's wanda the who when when and where
and our next question is how will
multiverse of madness permanently change
the broader reality of the marvel
cinematic universe
right yeah what's the post-credits scene
of this one are we talking mutants are
we talking
doom are we talking something else um
i think uh uh i don't know like
obviously mutants are coming into the
mcu
i think it's gonna be a bit early right
because we know all the titles
uh through it seems like the end of 2023
fantastic four is on the other side of
that and then there's been announced
uh a deadpool uh three unannounced blade
so you know for better or worse the
mutants aren't anywhere
on that lineup so like if anything if i
think what the post-credits scene is
it's gonna be for a movie that we know
is coming i would imagine
as opposed to like oh charles xavier
plays chess
with dr strange even though that's still
my my reach theory i want it to be
it is with dr shades in westchester new
york playing chess with the
charles xavier that's that's what i want
i just think realistically
it's gonna be something like i don't
know blade or
you know it's gonna tie in something
like that something supernatural
i mean like i i it could i mean yes that
is most likely i definitely agree
but like it could very much tie into
like a potential next big bad in the mcu
and i think it this doctor's training to
multiverse of madness could end up
teasing uh the builders into the uh
because if you if you guys look very
carefully in uh guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 um
you can see all over mainly the um that
um
ship that rocket and yondu bring in to
uh save the guardians
there's a lot of builder machine code
all around the ship
and build a machine code is the language
of the builders who are this
amazing like amazing threat to them
like i don't mean to be like oh man i
love threats to the universe but like
they they're one of my favorite villains
because they kick off this amazing uh
intergalactic war
with superheroes like it's basically the
marvel star wars
um the builder war and like the builders
are connected to this event called the
incursions which is like the
basically the ending of the marvel
multiverse when
because one reality was ended early all
the realities sort of tried
start to like smoosh into each other and
um you know
anyway the builders are very much tied
to uh
you know the that sort of cosmic and
primordial and like
you know the multiversal side of things
so i think that we could
get a builder tease there but that's
just me being no
i know dude hold on to that theory write
it down because that could end up being
the case
i mean it'd be great if like the post
credits seen something like the
illuminati
marvel illuminati right that's how you
get it doctor strange
um normally you'd have iron man part of
that you have to kind of recast it with
different people
uh have a read richards there or
something like that i mean normally
black panthers kind of tied him with
that too i know i'm so
sad that he's not going to be involved
in this because of obviously
charles passing but like yeah i love the
illuminati they're so sketchy and
they're saying
it'd be so cool just a sense of like a
behind the scenes group of people who
are like
super powerful trying to just like have
a superhero you in
or even like a league of sorcerers you
know uh
at the end like doctor straight just
just like okay we are the people of this
planet that know how to use magic and
included in that would be the wakandans
because they have the ancestral plane
the heart-shaped herb there is a type of
mystical magic to that
so i'd love for them to lead that
conversation
that'd be dope that's just totally true
those are all true facts
so yeah well uh let us know your
theories in the comments below but
that's it for this episode of inside
marvel
mt and i are going to be back every
friday until june 9th
we're going to be covering all the
biggest marvel news over these next
couple weeks as we wait for loki
uh and then a reminder on june 9th the
day of loki's premiere that's gonna be a
wednesday inside marvel will shift from
fridays to wednesdays
uh wednesdays my dudes we're gonna move
to wednesdays
uh follow mt at mastertainment follow me
at ea voss follow new rockstars and
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast subscribe to rockstars
on youtube and we thank you for watching
we'll see you next time bye
take it easy guys
[Music]
you